thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
wow Sam I I can't believe it's week six
brother it's we're here it's week six
season is flying by
it's insane man it's insane it uh how
are you feeling about the Slate today
oh I'm feeling uh
feeling yeah I'm feeling uh you know
feeling feeling good feeling confident
positivity
but you you know how they you know how
Vegas is bro you know how Vegas is
around week six is where they start to
you know this is where they start to get
you kinda I'm gonna be honest Sam this
is where they start to get you uh from
earlier on in the season but there's
there's two games there's two games that
caught my attention this week we got a
division match up the Cowboys taking on
the Eagles and also the bills and the
Chiefs
bills and the Chiefs is is is is is uh
they're playing a day and Sam I was
talking to Ryan before the show bro and
I I think I want to start it off with a
parlay man I don't know if you're vibing
with my parlayer if you might Vibe with
my parlay but let's bring Ryan in
because uh Ryan we gotta set them up
with this parlay we've been talking
about before the show what better way
than starting off a show with the parlay
talk to him right tell them what we were
talking about so what a day the sky is
blue the grass smells fresh it's an odd
it's a beautiful autumn day and it's a
great day for the Dallas Cowboys to win
a football game we like the Cowboys
money line plus 215 and the Chiefs money
line at home their home dog somehow
against the Buffalo Bills the two
biggest games of the day were taken
underdogs on the money line for a two
pick parlay that is plus 593. there it
is
there it is
you guys asked for odds we gave you odds
you guys asked for parlays we gave you a
parlay you guys asked for six bets bets
it's time to give you guys six Best Bets
I'm next to my man the guru Sam the
sharp Richmond my man's been hot this
year if you guys haven't been tapped
into the show now you guys know he has
been hot this year and uh we are looking
for those Trends to continue starting
over to my far I think left of you guys
are right of you guys it's producer Ryan
that's producer Ryan he's getting out of
here we'll see you later producer Ryan
Sam talk to me talk to the people
brother we're here for you we're here
for your locks give the people what they
want
well I I gotta say I do not
self-proclaim myself to be a guru you
guys will call me a guru and then the
commenters will yell at me and say why
the hell do we care about this guy and
they scream at me so just let the record
show that I don't refer to myself as
Guru but I do want to win myself money
and the audience money today so uh so
should we should we just get into it
let's get into it
all right do I have a timer or all right
I got the timer all right 45 seconds is
on the clock
all right we're starting with the game
of the year I am on the opposite side of
you and Ryan today
um I'm first of all I'm just so excited
that this game is is happening this is
going to be amazing rematch of the Epic
playoff game from last year but look I
think I think a lot of me thought the
bills were probably a little over hyped
coming into the year but tip my cap to
them they are the best team in football
right now full stop they are absolutely
lead on both sides of the ball obviously
the Chiefs are Dynamic offensively but I
think the thing that trips them up here
is their past defense it's a little
suspect they're ranking 20th and past
defense dvoa that is not a good thing
when you're facing Josh Allen Gabe Davis
Stefan Diggs uh so I like the bill say
to get it done time brother time time
you tried to get you tried to get those
last words in after the clock Sam next
time I might be sharp I might I might
just cut you off right there at 44.9
seconds it's bro because uh we we gotta
be on time and I didn't really like your
pick I'll be honest I'm I'm on the other
side but that's okay it's all love it is
all love Sam uh let's go to the comments
let's go to the comments producer Ryan
are the people in the comments are they
liking this pick this is one of the big
the biggest game of the week this is the
game of the week actually are they like
insane
they like the bills money line uh not as
much as a single play as it is a parlay
I see uh sukra Singh says Bill's money
line and Jets plus the points in a
parlay trig away says Bills win margin
1-13 I feel like that's not bad right I
mean if they're gonna win this game or
they're really gonna blow out the Chiefs
right right um
we've got quack 99 saying Eagles money
line I mean I don't know how many times
I have to tell the comments with the
Philly takes get get out of here uh and
then uh let's see we've got Alan beers
bills W so they're actually to start off
the show for the first time Sam there
seems to be they seem to be all over you
yeah
yeah that was a good play
I I will say this because I think a lot
of people with a short spread are like
should I just take bills minus two and a
half instead of money line I would be
pretty careful about that in this game
and I think if you like the Chiefs I
would take the points because both these
teams are really aggressive and if it's
closely they're probably going to go for
two so you might see a one point win in
this game so if you like the Chiefs I'd
probably take the points if you like
bills I would take money line
that Sam's version of uh adding on to
his 45 seconds I tried to sneak that in
there it didn't work it didn't work I'm
sorry
there there he is added on to his 45
seconds trigger way with the uh with the
with the bills winning by what was it
zero to ten points uh right one to
thirteen bills yes sir I like that I
like that I like that one uh all right
here we go let's move on let's move on
let's get producer Ryan you back with
the comments Sam spotlight's back on you
you gave us one pick what's the next one
all right so now I'm gonna get back to
my roots and go with the gross pick that
people hate I like the Saints today I
get it they're missing pretty much their
entire receiving core uh it's Andy
Dalton but Andy Dalton has sneakily led
a very good offense that thing has been
humming Kamara Payson Hill has actually
been good this year they're gonna lean
heavily on power Rush they're gonna try
and control the ball and and hold on to
and keep it out of burrows hands and I
think the thing that people don't
realize is quietly the Bengals just
aren't very good now I know I'm gonna
look like an idiot when they blow them
out but they have just not been a very
good team this season uh they really
weren't even that Elite last year until
the playoff run so I think this team is
just sort of average give me the Saints
plus three at home in a great
environment uh I like New Orleans there
it is Sam hey super Bose hangovers are a
thing I will tell you guys that once
again Super Bowl hangovers are a thing
and we're seeing it with those
Cincinnati Bengals we are seeing it with
those Cincinnati Bengals Andy and shout
out to you Sam I do like what Andy
doll's been doing in New Orleans uh
that's two
let's go to three you gave us two now
let's go to your third pick which way
are you leaning which way are you riding
45 seconds is on the clock
all right so I just repeat myself on
this show every week but I just continue
to believe so much in this raven scene I
think they're absolutely one of the
elite teams in the league and I think
the advanced metrics kind of back that
up number one pass offense dvoa number
three overall dvoa this team is loaded
and again I just I don't believe in the
Giants very much I think it's kind of
smoke and mirrors that they're that
they're foreign one
um really below average defense ranked
really bottom of the league and pass
defense again against Lamar Jackson that
is kind of a killer
um what they do well is run the ball the
Giants do but again I just don't know if
that matters that much in a game that
they're gonna be playing from behind a
lot I think Daniel Jones is going to be
forced to pass and that is not a good
thing for the Giants so I like Baltimore
to get it done today
Baltimore to get it done Sam's taking
the spread uh I like that one Sam I I
like that one Mark Andrews he is on my
fantasy team hopefully he can get back
in the end zone this week cashed on that
last week by the way asked on that last
week by the way all right Sam that's
three down three more to go
what's the next pick brother
all right so you're not gonna like this
one but I do really like this play I
like the Falcons today I'm a huge Niners
guy in general I just want to say that
but Greg I think even you would admit
the injuries for this team are out of
control they are missing I'm gonna read
off Bosa armstrad Ken law Ward Mosley
trick Williams like they are missing
their entire team and especially on the
defensive end and when you're missing
that many guys uh and that defense is
not as absolutely lead as it is and you
kind of need Jimmy G to sort of lead a
big win I kind of I I think they win the
game but I think it's a field goal game
uh and I think the Falcons are sneaky
pretty good they're 10th in offensive
Dua they really run the ball well uh
Mariota is gonna have an easier time
back there the Niners missing all their
passes
you're talking about you're going
against my team so I have to cut you off
brother but but but honestly
I don't I I kind of like your bed sharp
monkeys
they're missing too many guys they are
missing a lot of guys a lot of money is
on the sidelines today for the San
Francisco 49ers uh the sharp money is
also on the side of Sam
but uh I don't know if Atlanta's seen a
defense like the San Francisco 48 I
understand I don't know if they've seen
a defense to that caliber we talked
about both of being now and that is
going to be a big impact but I just
don't know if they've seen a defense
like the San Francisco 49ers uh I know
somebody who might no my boy producer
Ryan
do you know if the cow I mean if you do
you know if the Atlanta Falcons won if
do you know if they've seen a defense
like the 49ers and two I want you to
tell me if the comments are talking
about Sam's plays that he just mentioned
uh the Falcons have yet to see a defense
like the 49ers I'm not sure any team has
seat I don't know I'm not sure we've
seen a defense like the 49ers that's how
good they've been playing but they're
missing so many guys it's not that I
mean it's a very good defense still
they're still missing a ton of guys Sam
Sam next man up next man up next man up
that's the mentality that's what the
teams do come on we'll see uh
TJ Red Skull
uh likes chalk I guess go in Raven's
money line I what is that it's like must
minus 230. yeah that's true that's a
parlay that's a parlay leg I will say
this if you like the total and the
Giants Ravens game uh in the last 15
Giants home games the under is 14 and
one that's awesome right that's all I'll
say uh Razer says Saints will be eights
uh bars uh Carl's says Bengals o-line is
trash uh Jake minjin 49ers will roll
your trolling so here's the problem Sam
you started off hot and now the comments
have turned on you like it usually
happens this is how it goes
yeah
that's what happens when you fade the
49ers I don't know the comments they
just seems to like you know
I don't know it seems to start because
you got your wings only in there
yeah
we have a ATL Bravos saying next man up
get out of here with that trash uh next
man wait hold on we're not getting out
we're no we're staying here with that
trash because the next man up actually
the next pick is up producer Ryan we're
sending you back to the comments Sam you
got four you gave us four picks I didn't
really like the last one that's okay
that's okay we got two more picks talk
to me talk to me nice which way are you
leaning
so I I really like the Seahawks today
um like do you know Smith is legit man
it just is what it is that has been the
number one pass offense dboa in football
that offense has been amazing he has
been better than Russell Wilson was for
them for the past few years he's been
incredible I I think the wrong team is
favorite here I think the Seahawks at
home uh are are arguably better than the
Cardinals the Cardinals Advanced metrics
are really bad again they're they're
kind of bottom 23-24 in both offensive
and defensive dvoa on the road in a
really tough environment in Seattle uh I
like Geno Smith to get it done I know
their defense stinks but again I just
don't see the Cardinals as a team that
is going to be able to exploit that I I
think the Seahawks win in a shootout
I like that you stayed on time
and uh that's it the buzzer's in my head
man
that that's an interesting take uh Sam
one thing I did notice though bro and
now they did a they did a click they did
a uh they did a clicker on me they like
as many times as I said uh rookie last
week they did a counter on me actually a
counter as many times as I said rookie
last week I want to know how many times
Sam says dvoa this this this
uh this actually this segment you love
dvoa some brother well I got I gotta
explain it because last time when I
picked uh the Cardinals and I talked
about the Eagles Rush defense not very
very good I'm citing dvoa Advanced
metrics and Eagles fans yelled at me and
were like no they're eighth in the
league in defensive Rush rankings it's
like no I don't care about yards per
game I care about the actual Advanced
metrics so I have to oversay it but uh
but uh but yeah I'll try and fix that
big metrics guy
love metrics love numbers
all about the metrics hey Sam gave us
five he gave us five we got one more
left talk to a Sam talk to the people
which way are we leaning
all right ear muffs Ryan earmuffs
Cowboys fans to me this is this is your
sell high on Cooper Rush spot
um look I I'm the Cowboys won last week
that's great Cooper rushed through for
100 yards uh and that offense did not
move the ball very well they obviously
had the defensive touchdown and the punt
block and again that's great Cowboys
defense is amazing do I think they're
going to do that again and can you count
on a defensive score uh I don't see it
and I think the Eagles defense is really
good and I think if you're in a
situation where you're asking Cooper
rush to match Jalen hurts and that
electric Philly offense against a really
good defense uh I just personally don't
see it so everything's going right for
Philly right now and baseball and
football and everything they're gonna
win 90 to nothing because Philly can't
lose
there it is there it is it's time Sam uh
Philly minus six hmm interesting Ryan
welcome back into the show uh we wanna
know I wanna know what a fraud what a
fraud this guy is
what are the people talking about how do
you feel and what are the people talking
about right all right the people want
some questions answered I'm not
addressing this is Philadelphia
propaganda Sam got owned by Philly this
weekend and he's trying to jump on their
bandwagon uh I'm real ugly says this New
England money line a good play
ugh I I would not to stay away from me
there I actually think this is kind of a
sneaky good spot for the Browns
um though I do like zappy and as Mac
Jones officially out right has that been
announced yes
I do like zappy but uh the Browns have
actually been pretty good and just kind
of been the victim of some bad luck so
uh to me stay away lean Browns fading
zappy fever Sam Goldstein Jets or
Packers Assuming he's talking about the
points
oh
um God that game was a total stay away
for me because I just don't think the
Packers are good enough to cover a large
spread right now and I also think the
Jets are pretty fraughty even though
they looked good against the Dolphins
12th string quarterback last week so
total stay away for me I guess I just
take the points I guess I would take the
seven and a half gun to my head but I
don't love it
that line now has moved to eight by the
way so you're not getting that yeah uh
red snake says uh every week the
comments complain and every week this
guy ends up ahead fade the comments
I had to throw you a bone I had to throw
it thank you that is that is kind though
uh in the honor of transparency I did go
two three and one last week but then
that was our first losing week of the
year so let's I'm be transparent when I
lose I own it uh when I want when I win
I'll dance and vibe in your face so uh
but I will own it when I lose
accountability that's the motto of the
show last one and then and then we'll
we'll move on here uh Doug beags says
bird gang I had to I had to feed into my
to my Philadelphia people there
um what year Mets where's your met
spanner uh it disappeared just like the
Mets season completely gone and vanished
yeah yeah so uh but yeah keep dropping
your keep dropping your comments keep
dropping your questions we'll answer as
many as we can uh but that's uh that's
the comments guys there it is Ryan
Ryan's with the comments I'm over here
in the comments myself looking at him
seeing if I could see something
interesting uh but let's move on because
we're moving on to a part of the show
where we've been hot we told you guys
Sam's been hot even though last week he
took a little look took a little bump in
the road but that's okay we're back on
track this week but we've been hot in
the anytime touchdown score I'm gonna
boost at any time touchdown score for
you like I just mentioned we've been hot
we've hit in the last three weeks we've
hit every boost that we've done in the
last three weeks Ryan pull up those odds
talk to me what are the people saying
so these are the most bet anytime TDS on
DraftKings number one Travis Kelsey I
mean you're getting him at -125 after he
just scored four touchdowns no shocker
uh Nick Chubb in there at number two
against the Patriots at minus 145. uh
Mike Evans who's kind of been a
touchdown machine going up against the
Steelers I'm not sure Mike Evans will
play all four quarters that's how much
of a blowout this might be but he's at
-115. uh Cooper cut minus 155 at number
six and Aaron Jones all the way at the
bottom we just talked about Jets Packers
minus 130 a little bit of a time share
there with AJ Dylan but he's been
getting his own and getting into the end
zone so those are your most bet anytime
TDS at DraftKings make sure you drop
your takes uh in the comments as to who
you're betting today
make sure you guys drop those takes in
the comments Ryan actually let's go to
the comments bro what are they saying
are they giving us any hints in the
comments at all
uh so we got trigger away saying Dalvin
cook and Nick Chubb one is not enough
for him he needs both uh Doug beags Dion
Jackson
uh Max rexell says Aaron Jones
Steve dab Leonard fournette only one
touchdown the entire season so he's
fading that uh
and then Trey de Ruth says uh Cowboys
are gonna put on a show tonight I that
had nothing to do with any type TD I
just felt the need to say that all right
Ryan Ryan that was a lot that was a lot
I know here we have to we have to you
know we have to decide we got to make a
decision so let's let's let's bring that
in a little bit which which way are we
going who should we ride with you see
any other names in the comments so I'm
seeing I'm seeing Travis Kelsey because
of what he just did but also I see a lot
of Aaron Jones uh and like we had
mentioned there is a little bit of a
time share there but I think we might be
getting that at a good number if we go
Aaron Jones the comment is split I won't
lie it's between Travis Kelsey and Aaron
Jones usually we Galvanize around one
but we're seeing a lot of Aaron Jones
in the comments too I see a lot of Aaron
Jones therefore we are locking it in
we're riding with it we're riding with
Aaron Jones I think he's at minus 130 at
minus 130 yes sir there it is at the
bottom of the screen you guys know what
I could do for you I just told you guys
at the beginning of the segment we are
going to boost it so
poof there is the magic you guys see it
we boosted that up from minus 130 to
plus 100 before we go before we go who
are you riding with to score a touchdown
today Sam talk to me which way are you
right
I like digs man he's been getting a ton
of looks uh I think the chief's probably
gonna pay a lot of attention to Gabe
Davis after what he did to them in the
last playoffs so uh I think Diggs is
gonna gonna do some work today
Sam's rocking with Stefan Diggs I'm
rocking with Kenneth Walker III the
Seattle running back uh he's taken over
he's taking over for the injured penny
and I think that my man's gonna uh he's
gonna come out of shell a little bit Sam
he's also on my fantasy team so it's a
it's a it's a it's a win-win situation
for me uh if you guys want to combine if
you guys want to combine my picks Sam's
pick and your pick Draft Kings will
boost it by 25 check our low check our
social accounts check our social
accounts for more details on the BR
betting Pay Dirt parlay all right this
is my favorite part of the show guys
this is my favorite part of the show
Ryan pull up the specials on DraftKings
please
because I want to talk about something
me and Ryan was we was going through
DraftKings the other day and I saw
something that really really really
caught my attention the weekly specials
that draftking offer are absolutely
amazing here's one that I want to talk
about you guys tell me guys what you
think Ryan scroll down to the bills and
the Chiefs please because this is a game
that everybody's been talking about this
is Sam mentioned the game of the week
uh but if you guys look at the screen
Josh Allen Patrick Mahomes 600 plus
yards
seven touchdowns sitting at plus 450.
this one absolutely caught my attention
I mean both of these guys are coming off
four touchdown performances last week
both have been hot on fantasy if you
guys don't know both of them are one of
the quarterbacks that you want on your
team last year let's talk about last
year a little bit they put on a show in
the divisional round they were around
these numbers of these parlays Ryan
actually run through some of the stats
from that game for us bro all right yeah
so this was this was a shootout and if
we're going for bass entirely off of the
quarterback numbers which is what your
bet is based off of Josh Allen in that
game
329 yards 29 yards passing four
touchdowns Pat Mahomes
378 yards passing so you could bind
those passing yards boom you're way over
600 way over way over forget about it
it's way over it's not even close it's
not even close and the passing
touchdown's three so they they got seven
they got right at seven at way over 600.
so we're running it back
hey why not run it back that's how I'm
feeling Sam how are you feeling about it
I mean it's definitely interesting my my
only concern is uh Josh Allen rushing
for a touchdown them throwing for six
combined and Josh Allen sneaking one in
and breaking your heart because you're
gonna get to get to Seven TDS total but
one of them's gonna be a run so that's
just the pessimist in me because uh this
past weekend was was very sad for me
um but I wish you the best of luck
we needed Positive Vibes all Positive
Vibes all positive energy is appreciated
Sam thank you bro thank I I accept that
I I accept that hopefully Josh Allen
runs and then he also throws for like
four more so yeah I accept that Ryan how
are you feeling about the parlay I think
you're digging it but then also tell me
what the audience is talking about
uh
uh well Ryan abadilla says Chief spills
uh Bill's game will move 10 times slower
than last year uh as a member of the
Ryan Community I I don't I don't back
that take uh trig away says Diggs
getting in the end zone today uh there
listen this audience is still hung up on
on anytime TD if I could be completely
honest they're they're they're not over
the fact that that we didn't pick all of
their picks we got Tyler Lockett takes
in here uh
let's see Legend dig says this one's uh
this one's a head scratcher that's a lot
of yards and not normal for two Elite
quarterbacks so I I'm confused on where
where the chat's at because this I think
when you're watching a game like this
you root for points all you want is
points all you want is back and forth a
legendary shootout and they're not they
don't want to take this it seems like
they don't want to take the legendary
shoot uh I'm not really feeling the
comments with not trying to take the
legendary shooter I think that this one
might be a legendary track meet might be
a track meet out there uh
let's let's let's let's let's let's
let's
move on let's move on ride with me on
DraftKings you guys can ride with me on
DraftKings go check it out uh let's move
on let's move on Ryan pull up the pull
up the top player props on DraftKings
so we can see there they are
yeah so no shocker again we have a ton
of quarterbacks and quarterbacks who I'm
sure you've heard their name before
interesting enough I I want to point out
before we get before we do some over
unders here Evan McPherson has somehow
made this list his over one and a half
field goals made at minus 115. he's in a
dome today in New Orleans so you know
you shouldn't really have any issues
there if he if he is called on to kick
but I don't know we usually see a ton of
quarterbacks a ton of running backs wide
receivers interesting to see a kicker in
here Jeff Wilson Pops in your Guy Greg
uh over 65 and a half rushing yards
today
um so yeah and then of course a bunch of
you know Josh Allen rounds it out at
seven and eight there uh game of the
year today against the Chiefs so
that's our most bet player props at
giraffe Kings guys there it is there it
is some emergency options emergency
options if you guys need some emergency
picks we got Nick Chubb over under 91
and a half rushing yards Matt Ryan over
or under
oh actually actually
let's get to it let's let's get to it
Matt Ryan over or under five
interceptions Gabe Davis over under
three and a half receptions uh
let's get let's let's let's Sam
tell me if these are over under tell me
if these are over under
Ryan
get in get in get in the script you tell
us if these are over under actually bro
yeah and listen I know Matt Ryan has
been playing terrible this year Greg it
0.5 0.5 not five interceptions as much
as I think he probably can throw five
interceptions that might be worth a
sprinkle it is 0.5 interceptions for
Matt Ryan today so you guys going over
or under that
we'll take over we'll take over Sam
Sam's going over 0.5
he stinks
that's my analysis
I'm going over
over okay we've got Angelo in the chat
Josh Allen over 37 and a half past
attempts
oh it's an interesting that's an
interesting one I like that one
that is a lot
um
a lot that is a lot of attempts that's a
lot okay last game that these teams
played Gabe Davis popped off went for
four touchdowns caught four touchdowns
they might have been the only passes he
caught actually but he scored four today
his reception uh over under is three and
a half you guys going over or under that
yeah I'm going under there I think
people you look at his numbers his
Target rate is really down that's kind
of why I like Diggs as my anytime TD for
this week because he they're just not
getting him the ball a lot even like
last week where he had like 160 yards
it's on what like two three catches
um so I'll take the under there cool I'm
believing in the shootout believe in the
shootout I know over we're all in on the
shootout today Greg uh b-man Matt Ryan
250 plus yards
is this like the Matt Ryan segment yeah
why why are we on Matt Ryan Matt Ryan
has had a terrible year under I mean you
can't trust that guy to do anything
right now
that was I know they won that game that
was one of the worst quarterback
performances I've ever seen uh against
the Broncos he was so bad yeah awful
horrendous I mean that was one of the
worst games of the year and then we got
commanders Bears on Thursday night and
they they lost commanders Bears great
yes awesome uh B webs Jags and Colts
under 20 and a half first half total
points
again I think the Colts offense is
horrendous and I think their defense is
doing a really good job of keeping them
in games
um so I'll go under there
yeah I'm going under two the offenses no
they're not they're not talking to me I
will say uh our good friend uh Mike
Ritter always says don't bet on the
Atlanta Falcons just because they're too
weird I personally can never bet on a
Colts Jaguars game it is always the
weirdest thing in the world always
because I feel like the Colts do well in
Indianapolis but they're like they go
travel to Jacksonville and for some
reason forget how to play football it is
in Indianapolis today though uh but
that's a stay away for me but uh yeah
those are the player props guys
there it is there it is uh let's let's
go to the comments Ryan let's go to the
comments what are they talking about are
they saying anything anything
interesting yeah so you guys want to
grade some bets here let's grade some
bets why not all right uh Jack
boyzo Nick Chubb
not one touchdown guys
two touchdowns
what do you think
I like that oh
I'll I'll give you like a B I actually
like Trump a lot today it's just that's
just risky two TDS but uh the Patriots
are definitely beatable on the ground so
I I do like that play
Patriots are beatable on the ground Nick
Chubb is the horse he's the horse out
there in Cleveland
he's also on my fantasy team so that's
why I gave it an a all right uh Jay Frye
Philly gets exposed tonight
Cowboys money line
no I just need to see it okay yep
so what we'll do is check this out yeah
yeah no not the only reason why that's
the only reason why I asked that one if
Philly rolls you then I'm clipping this
out and I'm gonna I'm gonna roast you so
just know that's also coming I think
we're gonna get humbled bro I think
they're gonna get humble it's it's
always when that that that undefeated
team they takes that that humbling uh
loss and then they get better from it
and I think Philly maybe not this week
but I think it's coming soon
uh all right uh who's next says Mark
Andrews anytime touchdown
oh yeah
it's Plus 100.
so even money I like it Ravens roll
today you're a tough teacher Sam I feel
like you don't give out Ace
I don't unless it aligns exactly with
what I've personally bet uh you're not
getting an A okay that's yeah that's for
I also don't think you give your your
class like needs a curve I feel like
exactly yeah tough teacher class needs a
curve
uh gig 26 Saints team total over 19.
oh
um well I like the Saints today I I
don't think they're exactly gonna like
light up the scoreboard so again I'll
stick with the B uh don't hate it
um I think it's probably right around
there but I do like them to to get it
done today
uh Angelo hurts two plus passing
touchdowns
um
the problem with Hertz is he and I give
the Eagles credit a lot is they do
sneaks their coach actually knows that
on the goal line just have him lean
forward so he gets a lot of cheaties on
the ground so uh I can't find the sea
but I'd probably just give it a c
because again what's gonna happen is
he's gonna rush for one or one rush for
two and then you're gonna hate your life
but uh but that that's my only concern
with that one
okay uh sonoa Kyler Murray over
282 over 288 and a half all-purpose
yards
All Purpose all-purpose
oh god um I threw my C on the ground so
I have to pick it up but
um I'll I'll go see I don't hate it it's
fine kind of a pass for me
um Seahawks defense does stink I'll give
them that but uh I just I don't know not
necessarily a Kyler Murray guy okay uh I
want to go to Mike uh Mike Ritter here
who says uh Garrett Cole six plus case
seven plus hits allowed today against
the Guardians
I don't want to talk about baseball
their baseball killed you this weekend
no no no no no no baseball talk we are
all football here we are all football uh
Hey guys we've reached that time we
reached that time of the show I'm pretty
sure there was tons and tons of winners
throughout the show hopefully you guys
at home was able to tap in and ride
along with us uh my name's Greg Ivory
for Sam Richmond and producer Ryan we
are out of here peace
foreign
[Music]